ولسان كبير للكتف
ثم فصل الأرجوحة المثالية ،
هذا ما أمضاه hidemizawa حياته
المهنية في تدريس أفضل لاعبي الجولف
اليابانيين بما في ذلك hideki matsuyama الذي صنع
التاريخ الشهر الماضي كأول
رجل ياباني وآسيوي يفوز بالبطولة الرئيسية
mezawa هو أول مدرب يتأرجح ماتسوياما
من أي وقت مضى
قال ماتسوياما ، الذي هو خجول وهادئ
للجمهور ،
هو رجل مختلف عن الأخضر ، هل هو
مختلف
في الحياة الخاصة عنه في الأماكن العامة ، يبدو
كما تقول خجولًا جدًا وغير عاطفي
بالنسبة للمشاهد ، لكنك تعرفه شخصيًا أكثر
ما هو  كما
لو أنه عندما يكون مع فريقه مثل المدربين ،
فهو ليس خجولًا ، أخبرني
أنه يهتم حقًا
بالناس والأشخاص من حوله ، فهذا جزء مما
أحترمه عنه ، كما يقول
بمجرد بدء البطولة ، فإنه
يركز على ذلك لذا قد ترى وجهه الجاد
أكثر  في كثير من الأحيان ولكن على انفراد ،
يبتسم كثيرًا وهو رجل جميل
قبل أن يكافح الأسياد ماتسوياما
لأنه لم يفز بالبطولة
منذ عام 2017.
وصف ماتسوياما مدربه الجديد بأنه رائع
يشتهر lp matsuyama بالثقة في
غرائزه الطبيعية
لماذا تعتقد أنه جاء إليك
قبل أن يصبح مدربه ، لقد لعب
بطريقته الخاصة كما يقول
عندما كان يفوز ، ربما كان بإمكانك
القول إن غرائزه كانت صحيحة
ولكن خلال السنوات القليلة الماضية عندما كان
لم يستطع الفوز بغرائزه ربما
لم يكن يعمل بشكل صحيح ، كما يقول
مايزاوا قال إن أحد مجالات التركيز الرئيسية
لتدريبه كان الدقة عند نقطة
التأثير ولكن ما لاحظه المراقبون أكثر
هو أن التوقف في الجزء العلوي من
ظهره قد أصبح أقصر
ماتسوياما  معروف بالتوقف في الجزء
العلوي من ظهره ،
ما هو رأيك في ذلك ،
لم أعلمه أن يغير أنه
يقول إنه تم إصلاحه عندما كنا نصلح
أشياء أخرى
قالها وكيف تعمل مع ماتسوياما
كيف عملتما معًا  قرر ما الذي نركز عليه
ناقشنا الأجزاء الجيدة والسيئة من
اللعب
يقول مايزاوا إن الأشهر التي
سبقت الماجستير كانت عمل
جماعي مكثف مع
مدرب ماتسوياما البدني وعلبة
ماتسوياما تريد بشدة أن تصبح
مخدرًا  أخبرني أحد اللاعبين
دائمًا بالتفكير تحت الضغط
والقتال من أجل ذلك ،
كنت أعلم أنه لن يكون من السهل دعم
شخص مثله وكنت مستعدًا لذلك
فهو يخطط لدعم ماتسوياما لبقية
مسيرته ويقول إذا كانت الألعاب الأولمبية ستقام
ستكون لحظة تاريخية أخرى
لماتسوياما
فرصة للفوز بأول ذهبية أولمبية له
على
أرض الوطن سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن طوكيو